(audience chattering)
- Good to go?
Okay. Hello everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
I am Amanda Quinto
and I am a solutions architect in Brazil
responsible for public finances
for the past six years.
Today we are going to
talk about a little bit
so our secure AI agents
in delivery efficiency
in high regulated environments.
I'm here with two really nice
customers, Edson and Andries.
They are over there
and they will be presenting with me today.
So again, thanks for joining.
It's really nice to be in
re:Invent this year with you guys.
There's a little bit about our agenda.
So we are gonna talk about
high regulated environments
and how we can operate AI workloads
on top of those kind of environments.
And then, we are going to talk about
how we can use Amazon EKS to run
AI agents and AI workloads on AWS.
Edson will explain how is Sicoob using
this kind of environments to run workloads
for gen AI in high regulated environments.
We are going then to
move to Amazon Bedrock
and understand how can Bedrock help us
to deliver AI agents
and also stay inside of our regulations.
And then Holland casinos
represented by Andries
will be showing here for
you guys to understand
how they are using AgentCore
to run their workloads on AWS.
Okay. So let's get started.
We have about an hour here
and I will try to make you guys up.
I know it's really heavy event
and you guys walk a little bit
long distances to be here with us today.
So thank you again.
When we are talking about
high regulated environments,
we are no longer just thinking about
deploying models on AWS.
We need to operate inside
of dense amount of laws,
standards and patterns to
stay inside of the regulations
of our current countries.
Here we are representing
two different countries,
that's Brazil and Holland,
but we can see these movements
all around the globe.
Europe, for example,
has the Europe AI Act.
That is a movement with
strict risk based framework
that then some uses completely from AI
and also determine some
different obligations
for high risk systems to run both on cloud
or in the on premises environments
when we're talking about
data and AI workloads.
Brazil is combining their
emerging AI legislations
with the legislations that
already have on top of data.
Something like LGPD for example.
We also took two different patterns.
We have some obligations that's federal
for mostly data from public sector.
For example, we should stay with this data
inside of the Brazil.
And we also have some discussions
around data sovereignty.
And we also have some determinations
around specific industries.
So for example, my industry,
finances and public finances,
have some obligations that is
determined by central bank.
So we have, we received the
normatives from Central Bank
and we should make our customers to run
inside AWS respecting
this kind of obligations.
This is a worldwide movement.
We have today more than 1,000 different
AI regulations around the world.
This is representing
more than 69 countries.
So it is not easy to stay
inside of the regulations
as of providers such as AWS.
So we work specifically
in each customer cases
to deliver the best architectures
that fulfill this kind of requirements.
There is something common
when we are talking about
this kind of frameworks and obligations.
When we look into Brazil or
South America or United States
or Europe, there are always some pillars
that is similar in different scenarios.
So we have compliance and governance,
we have legal and privacy,
controls and risk management.
These four pillars always appear
in different normatives and
regulations around the globe.
And that can make for us
the bottom layer that we can
look into this and deliver
different architectures
that work for mostly
cases around the globe.
But again, there is different obligations
in different countries,
in different industries
that we need to always make sure
that we are responding correctly
for this kind of
environment and obligations.
So there is some patterns
that we can follow
so we can understand the customer needs,
their regulation needs
and stay on top of this
kind of obligations.
We can see this in a layered
pattern that can help us here.
So we have at the bottom,
we have the gen AI
application for example.
On top of this we have regulatory layers.
So as I said, it's
different from each country.
It's different for Europe,
it's different for Canadians,
it's different from Chile
and China for example.
And we need to be specific to here,
but there is other layers
that we can understand
in a broader way.
So for example, when we
talk about responsible AI
and in AWS responsible AI
is a really half pillar
that we are following from our customers
and also our services to deliver
Gen AI solutions for the customer.
So when we talk about responsible AI,
we have some pillars and
patterns when we talk about data,
when we talk about
safeguarding our customers,
when we're talking about security
and prompting engineering
structures that we can
be aware of malicious users for example.
So all of these kind of
discussions are inside
of the responsible AI layer in AWS.
So this is a really interesting content
that you guys should,
if you guys like this
kind of documentation
is really have documentation
and you should read about it
because there is a lot of
good instructions over there.
And if you follow the
responsible AI patterns,
you are probably going to be inside
of the obligations in your countries.
We also have compliancy and standards
and here we are talking
about ISOs we are going
to talk a little bit further about ISOs,
but it's important just to know
that there is specific ISOs
for specifically Gen AI workloads already.
So we are also looking to this
and we are also delivering
architectures on top of it.
And here we are talking more,
the technical aspects here in tow,
so it's a layered approach.
So we have the bottom
layers on the regulatory
and on top of this, we can think about
more technical perspectives.
So we can see NIST framework for example,
NIST 600 framework for example,
is a risk management framework for AI.
But as you know, NIST is just
a pattern that we can follow.
They don't really audit
your environment for this,
but we can look into this framework
and see if we are architecturing
our systems on Gen AI
following these patterns.
And then when we are going
to solve for some auditation
from the responsible
government or something,
we are going to probably be inside
of these obligations, okay.
So NIST AI framework 600
is a really good framework.
It's the main framework that United States
is following for their obligations,
and the laws and definitions
that you guys are following here in US.
On top of this, there is OWASP.
So OWASP are really common
when we are talking about,
for example, OWASP Top 10
vulnerabilities for security.
There is also the OWASP LLM
AI cybersecurity pattern.
So you can see the, it's improvement.
Actually it's been improved, actually,
but you can see what is the most common
vulnerabilities that can
appear in Gen AI workloads.
You can see how we can
achieve some techniques
to avoid this kind of problems.
So OWASP is always a good idea.
There's also OWASP top 10 vulnerabilities
for LLM applications.
So you should also be aware
and there are also changes
because it's really new.
So we are always having new,
new vulnerabilities here.
It's not a good thing,
but it's a pattern in the marketing.
And on top of all of this
we already have the AWS
well architected framework
layer for Gen AI applications.
So you guys should know the AWS
well architecture I believe.
And we have a bunch of different layers
for our six pillars and there is already
a layer for Gen AI workloads as well.
So it's a live document.
It's being proven as well,
but it's already live for our
customers to follow, okay.
So this layered regulation
and controls should help us
to build this kind of workloads on AWS,
following and maintain ourselves
inside of the regulations
from our countries, right?
Regulatories should not
stop the AI adoptions.
We think regulatory requires AI adoptions.
We can also improve regulatory
obligations using AI.
We can use AI to understand the regulatory
and then accelerate the AI
workloads on high regulated
environments, okay?
We can see this in government in Brazil,
we see this in financial sector,
we see this in health sector as well.
So we can also,
we can make them work together.
One should not stop the other, right.
Okay, so now we discuss a little bit about
how high regulators
works around the world,
how AWS positions
themselves on this matters.
Let's go dive deep into the
technical perspective now.
When we are talking about Gen AI in AWS,
there is three layers and
you're probably going to see
this is like a lot on re:Invent.
I'm going to be real quickly here
because this is most
probably the most used slide
for the AWS solutions
architects around the world.
But this is the AWS three layer
for generative AI stack, okay?
So from the top to the
bottom we have the Q family,
so the applications family.
We have the Amazon
bedrock, that is our suite,
our solution for all gen
AI workloads running.
We can run,
use different models,
we can use everything
on top of APIs on AWS.
And in the bottom here, we
have the infrastructure layer.
So we are going to talk about,
more about the infrastructure layer here
because of the Sicoob use cases.
And then we will detail this for you.
The infrastructure layer here,
there is, I don't know
two names here that makes
a lots of noise in the marketing.
There is Trainium and Inferentia.
They are ships specific developed by AWS
for machine learning workloads.
We also have SageMaker.
And in SageMaker there's a
whole world of solutions.
You can deliver different
kinds using machine learning
or Gen AI models if you want to.
But we are going to
talk about specifically
GPUs workloads here.
So in AWS we have a bunch
of different types of GPUs.
There is a disposability of
a lot of GPUs on our stack
and you're gonna understand
how we can use GPUs
to deliver Gen AI solutions
for high regulated environments, okay.
But in the heart of Gen AI,
there is a model, right?
There is some commonly used models here,
but before I think about the model,
you should understand your use case.
So what I'm trying to solve here?
What is my pain that I
needed to solve with Gen AI
and check if there is
actually a Gen AI solution
that I should use for this pain,
for this problem in my company.
Yes it is makes sense to use Gen AI
for this kind of workload.
All right.
So now then you should
find a model for this.
There's a bunch of them in the marketing.
We have also Amazon Nova and AWS.
After this you are
probably going to use two
or three models for your workload.
And you will probably going
to change this after a while.
Weeks and months after months,
we are seeing different models
arriving in the marketing
and one is better for one thing,
the other is better for another thing.
You should not be in love with your model.
You should use the best
model for your use case.
But there's a bunch of them models there.
You choose two or three that works better
for your use case, for
your scenario and go ahead.
So you use a foundation model.
You can both use it, RAG for example,
are prompt engineering
tools to solve your problem.
And just to make one quick comment here,
this is a 300 sessions.
So I'm sorry, my hair.
This is a 300 sessions.
So we're not going to explain what's RAG,
we're not going to explain
what is the prompt engineering,
but we are going to state
all of the events here
the solutions architect to help you with
that if you have some doubt, right?
So you choose your model,
you have your problem solved.
You need to understand if you're
going to use, for example,
prompt engineering or
RAG to make your data
inside of this model or in
parallel with this model.
That should work for you too.
If that doesn't work, you
can fine tune your model.
So there's a model you
can fine, get your data,
your specific data for
your specific industry
and fine tuning your model to fulfill
your use case, to solve your problem.
That works too.
It's not a easy task to do.
You need a lot of data
to do this properly,
but it works well when we are talking
about specific industries.
For example, in Brazil
we are seeing a movement
of financial sectors using
this, health sector using this.
And also public sector,
the government is
thinking about developing
and fine tuning the
large foundation models
with specific data.
So that should work for
some large use cases here.
But it's not an easy task to do
and you need lots of data.
Or you can train your own model.
This is really is a
heavy task to do as well,
but should work.
You should have a lot of data again.
You should use a bunch of
GPU to train your models,
but that works as well.
So you need to understand
which approach is better
for your workload, for your use case,
for the size of your company
and then move forward.
We have a model now that we can do.
We need to do the inference.
So in the heart there is a model,
but we need to deliver this model
for our application in a way
that we can do predictions.
we can do prompt engineering,
top of this model faster,
easier, with low latency
if you're talking about some
production workload for example.
You can also do batch predictions,
but you also need inference endpoint
that is generally
available, that's resilient,
that's secure as well for your workload.
So this is important here.
In AWS, there is three
different ways to do this.
We can use Amazon Bedrock
and we are gonna talk with
this a little bit further.
You can use SageMaker as well.
So there are specific models
that you can deploy on SageMaker
and you can also deliver endpoints
for making inference on SageMaker.
And you can use Amazon EKS.
There is a really interesting
movement running right now
and we are seeing this growing
on the AWS with Amazon EKS.
So if you search for
due on EKS, data on EKS,
there is a bunch of interesting materials.
We have a bunch of customers
using this around the globe.
But to use Kubernates
as your main platform
you need to understand that this is,
there's overhead on top of
your infrastructure team here.
So if already you are
using Kubernates to run
other kinds of workloads,
to run your workloads
in production in AWS, your
team already know the solution
that probably a path to go.
But if you don't know AWS,
don't know Kubernates rather,
you don't know Amazon EKS
and you're going to
discover this right when
you are trying to implement
generative AI workloads on AWS.
That's probably going
to be a hard task to do.
But I am a really fan of Kubernates,
and if you're doing this
here, you're probably going
to get some really outcomes
after all the overhead on your team, okay.
So, when you are using
Kubernates as the main platform,
here, we probably going
to already have some
main pillars for
production workloads on AWS
such as disaster
recovery, cost visibility.
We can have deployment
automations as well on Kubernates.
And we can deliver and
deploy our inference endpoint
and our generative AI
workloads on Kubernates.
So instead of deploying
Amazon EC2, for example
with GPU and run everything
inside of these EC2
and have problems with scalability
and have problems with
deployment automations
and disaster recovery,
you can put this inside of
Kubernates with Amazon EKS
and then run your Gen AI workloads
in these kind of architectures, okay.
I'm talking a little
bit more than I used to,
and it's really cold in here.
So I'm going to take some water here
but let's keep it going.
So, why customers choose EKS for inference
as we were discussing?
There's a bunch of good things
such as disaster recovery, scalability,
cost predictions as well.
We can have some tools for this.
But for me, the main goal,
the main reason is for
open source ecosystem.
So the open source
ecosystem for Kubernates
has been really good, really
dense material for the past,
I don't know, more than 10 years,
for different kinds of workloads
and for Gen AI workloads,
this is indifferent.
So there is a really good materials
for Kubernates in AI workloads
with the open source community.
They are always developing
new solutions for this,
so when this starts, I don't
know, one year and half ago,
we didn't have solutions for
deploying clusters with GPU.
We didn't have for example,
images that was GPU prepared.
We didn't have infrastructure
as code solutions for these.
But one year and half later,
we already have some project
that is really mature
and open source ecosystem
that supports this kind of
workloads all around the globe.
So again, if you guys like
this kind of materials,
you should search for data on EKS.
There is a bunch of interesting
materials over there.
We also have all these pillars here
for the recently introduced Kubernates.
The open source secret system
is the most interesting one.
You can also run this everywhere.
So you can run this on AWS,
you can run this in different providers.
You can run this inside of
your own infrastructure.
If you have, for some reason
you have GPUs over there,
you can make some tests on your on,
on premises environment for example.
So there's a bunch of
different reasons used here
that we can use EKS
And now, Edson will share a little bit
of the Sicoob case with us
and how they are using
this kind of architectures
to fulfill their business needs.
Okay, so Edson please.
Thank you.
- Thank you Amanda. Hello, everyone.
As Amanda said, my name is Edson Lisboa.
I am IT executive at Sicoob.
And Sicoob is one
of the largest cooperative
financial system in Brazil,
the cooperative union in Brazil.
And it's my pleasure to
be here with you today
during the next few minutes
to share on the re:invent stage
to share a little bit more
about our generative AI journey
and how a highly regulated
financial institution
is successfully adopting generative AI
at scale, keeping security,
governance, compliance
as non-negotiable pillars.
So let me start with who we are.
As I said,
Sicoob is a cooperative
financial institution in Brazil
and Sicoob is present in all
over the country.
As you know, Brazil is
almost a continental country
and Sicoob is present there.
And Sicoob offers almost the same
financial products and services
as a traditional bank does.
Sicoob is present in almost
2,500 Brazilian cities.
And it's very interesting to emphasize
that over 400 Brazilian cities
there is only Sicoob there.
We have more than 300 credit unions
integrated with our cooperative system.
We have 14 central co-ops
and we have 4,700 brands
in all over the country
with more than 60,000 employees.
All this structure serving
more than 9 million people in our country.
And it's very important to emphasize that
even considering this
presence in our country,
over than 98% of our transactions
are performing on our digital channels
such as mobile app and internet bank.
And as a financial institution in Brazil,
it means that we are living
under a very strict regulation
from our Brazilia Central Bank.
And for us governance it's not
only a compliance check box,
but it's really a true
competitive differentiator.
So we decided to create
a centralized structure
to control the decisions about governance
with clear accountability,
risky classification and
continuous monitoring.
And when we started our
generative AI journey,
we defined four unbreakable pillars
such as the first one, security.
As a financial institution for us,
the security of our credit unions
and members data is our priority.
The second one is scalability.
Considering our actual
numbers, as I had showed you
and considering our goals
for the next few years,
we really needed an environment
and a solution to support our size
and our growth needs.
So it was very important to us.
The third one, efficient cost management.
It was very important to us
run the large models
considering the strategy
pay as you go and considering the strategy
related of open source LLM adoption.
It was very important to us too.
And last but not least,
multiple LLM models.
We wanted to use the right
model to the right task.
We really believe that only one
model doesn't fit all needs.
And these are the open sources,
LLM models that we are using.
We are running on AWS using
Amazon EKS as Amanda said.
And the models Llama from Meta,
Mistral, PHI 4,
the Chinese model, DeepSeek R1
and the model from IBM named granite.
Sometimes we are using multiple models
side by side in the same use case
and in other case we can
choose a specific model
considering the fastest
or considering the most
accurate to this that subject.
And considering all this
strategy and this information,
Ms. Amanda will explain
a little bit more about
technical information of our environment.
Amanda, help me.
- Yeah. Thank you Edson.
Thanks for sharing.
Okay, so again, we have
a model as Edson said,
they choose their model,
they choose their problem,
what they are trying to
solve with generative AI,
they understand the regulated environment
and what obligations they should achieve.
And this is the architecture
that they are running
on AWS to solve these problems.
So we are going to discuss a little bit
about this architecture here.
It's actually a simple architecture.
In the core of this, we have
an Amazon EKS cluster, okay.
In Amazon EKS cluster,
we are deploying EC2 instances with GPUs.
To do this, there is a
bunch of best practices
that we are discovering with our customers
from the past one year,
one year and a half or so.
And we are trying to
bring here for you guys
when you're going to try
this on your specific cases.
So for example, you guys should
think about using specific AMIs
for generative AI workloads,
for GPU workloads.
So there is, for example,
drivers from Nvidia
that you don't want to
deploy it by your own.
There's a bunch of different versions
that you can have some problems
when you're deploying this.
So use specific AMIs.
Other good idea is to
download all the models
for Amazon Street for example.
So instead of downloading the model,
every time you run a new
pod inside of Kubernetes,
you can use this on Amazon Street
and it's really quickly
to deploy it on EKS
when you already have
the model here, okay.
So this is a good idea
when you are deploying this
kind of infrastructure.
But actually this isn't a
Kubernetes presentation,
so I'm trying not to go
so dive deep into the
Kubernetes perspective.
But there is two solutions,
two open source solutions
that's really helping
and making this workload,
makes sense for this workload on Sicoob.
So we know GPUs are expensive.
They are not cheapest
infrastructure. We know this.
So they are using Karpenter
to scale Kubernetes
with GPU instances on AWS.
So instead of just deploying
the instances based on the,
I don't know,
this model needs this shape of GPUs,
I will deploy my cluster
with this node groups and that's all,
they are using Karpenter to do this
using spotting instances
on EKS, on Kubernetes.
So instead of just leaving the GPUs
over there without utilization,
they pay as you go, as they
go, as you go as Edson said
and use these GPU instances
based on their needs.
But there is another
solution on top of this
that is also an open source
solution that is KEDA
that's for the grow,
I'm trying to not use
Kubernetes concepts here
to scalability the depots
inside of the cluster.
So whenever they received a
request from the environment.
So if they are not using the final users,
they have both inside users
and customers using this environment.
But the users are not
using the environment,
they don't run any pods,
so they don't deploy any GPU instances.
So they don't pay for it.
So the KEDA is used to scalability depots
based on the request.
So you receive the request
in this environment,
then we will deploy it for the end user.
It's something that you think about it
because took some time to deploy it,
but if there isn't, I dunno,
transactional workload
that's running inside of the
cluster, maybe the customer,
the end user or the
final customer can wait,
I dunno some seconds
over there to deploy this
to then start using
the generative AI model
or something like this.
So this works better for Sicoob
and that's why these
environments make so much sense
with this kind of architecture
combining Karpenter and
KEDA using EKS clusters,
they can deploy different models,
they can achieve different business cases
using these environments.
So there is a bunch of
different cases here.
Edson will explain for
you a little bit later
inside of the same cluster.
So the same cluster is running this.
To operationalize this,
they are using other two
open source solutions.
So as I said before, that's
one of the core reasons
that I believe that
Kubernetes makes so much sense
for Gen AI workloads.
The open source solutions,
I already talk about two.
Karpenter, it is developed by AWS
but it is an open source
solution and KEDA.
There's also another two.
So we have LiteLLM.
So instead of managing these
models inside of the cluster,
I dunno, in common line,
we can expose this for the
final users using LiteLLM.
So this is also an open source solution.
It's also somehow choose
how to deploy this on AWS
in our documentation.
It's a really nice
solution that you can use
to manage all these models
inside of the cluster.
So we have a customer interface,
end user interface that
you can run the models.
And also vLLM.
vLLM is a solution that is
actually new in this environment,
in Sicoob environment.
Before this, they were using a Llama,
but they achieve that using
vLLM, they have much more,
it is much more faster,
it's more compute optimized
to run the models.
And vLLM is actually a new solutions
and new open source tool
and is receiving improvements
from the community.
So it's probably going to be
even cheaper than we
started using this kind of
engine to run LLM models
on top of Kubernetes.
So this is here four open source solutions
that really makes sense for
them to run this workload,
to run different kinds of workloads
inside of the same cluster here.
And then we can also use other
AWS services around this.
So for example, we have Amazon ECR.
For the images, we are using Ingress
to expose the endpoint of the
models for the solutions with
AWS load balancers and
other other solutions.
But the main of the infrastructure
of the architecture here
is inside of the cluster.
So this kind of solutions
is really making sense
for this workload for them
and also deploying GPU instances on AWS.
When we use Karpenter,
we don't need to work on the heavy lift
of thinking about which
different instances
there is available in
this zone for example.
You can put three, in
Brazil, you have three zones.
We can put those three different zones
inside of the Karpenter manifests
and say, I should use this shapes of GPUs,
which one is better,
which one is available,
which one of these is cheaper?
You should deploy it on the cluster for me
and then let Karpenter works.
He does the works for you.
You can use budgets on Kubernetes
to arrange the way that
they took off your instance,
but they only took off your instances
or your spotting instance
after you have another one deployed.
So there is some ways to work
with spotting interruptions
when you are talking about
Kubernetes environments.
So there's a bunch of solutions
and tricks and tips here
that we can understand
how we can operate generative AI
inside of Amazon EKS cluster on AWS, okay.
But the main idea here is that we can run
different workloads
inside of the same cluster
with cost management achieved.
We are going to,
we are being able to run
this with some low overhead
on top of the team.
Okay.
So Edson will now explain
which are the outcomes
and what are the business
solutions that they are achieving.
- Thanks, Amanda.
Thanks, Amanda.
And now for me, is the most important part
considering the real use case
and considering the business results
using all these platform,
all these environment,
using these LLM models
as Amanda showed to you.
First of all, I would like to share
a little bit about our
internal intelligence
development assistant named Sisbr code AI.
Sisbr is the name of our
core banking platform
an we decided not to pay
or not to buy a specific solution
to integrate to our platform.
We decided to create our own solution
using these LLM models that I showed you.
And we integrated this solution
with IDEs of our developers.
Nowadays we have almost 1,500
developers in our company.
And there are a lot of benefits
of using Sisbr code AI,
like automate coding sites,
automate code recommendations
to the developers,
accelerate the process of
onboarding of new developers
was another benefit,
saves time to deliver new features
and new solutions to our
credit unions and our members.
And not only save times,
but also improves the
quality of our solutions
and continue support throughout
the development cycle.
The second one, our Backoffice automation.
Nowadays we have almost
eight digital robots
automating manual tasks
and not only simple manual tasks,
but complex manual tasks too.
And it's the reason
that we are using generative AI
integrated with our robots, AI agents.
And it was possible to save
almost 400,000 human hours
with this kind of solution.
Another interesting real use
case is our investment advisor.
It is a specialized support
for investments using generative AI
and it's possible to
create good recommendations
about investments to our investors
considering the member profile,
considering the best market practice
and for sure considering our products,
investment products offered
by our credit unions
to our members.
It was another very good solution
to our business every day.
And last but not least,
I would like to share about our core bank,
smart assistant named Sisbr AI.
There are a lot of
features in this solution
and it's possible such as,
it's possible to interact with documents,
not only normal documents,
but legal documents, contracts
and it's possible to interact
using natural language
and get good answers using generative AI.
And it's possible to do intelligent search
and it's possible to create analysis
and generate automatically
decision, credit loan decision reports
using generative AI
using this solution too.
And finally, I would
like just to emphasize
that there are a lot of other benefits
and results for the business considering
these use cases using generative AI
and other use case that we have.
And it is a good option,
a good option for our business
using this kind of solution.
So thank you for your attention.
And Amanda, stage is yours again.
- Again.
Yeah, thank you Edson.
Thanks for sharing.
Thanks for sharing the Sicoob journey.
For me, it's a pleasure
to be here with Sicoob.
We've been working together
for the past six years
in AWS with Sicoob.
So it's a really nice
case. Thank you Edson.
Thanks for your presence.
But okay, let's dive to the
second part of the presentation.
So we were talking about
high regulated environments
on top of Amazon EKS
and GPUs infrastructures
and now we are going to
talk about how we can build
AI agents on Amazon bedrock,
also covering the regulations
perspective, okay.
So let's go again in the most used slides
in the re:Invent.
So we have the, our two layer here
and now we are going to
talk about the middle layer.
So Amazon Bedrock is tool focus
on builders and developers.
So we are using building blocks
to deliver generative AI
solutions for our customers.
We start just, I don't know,
maybe in 2023 I believe
just with some models
and some endpoint for our
customers based on APIs.
And now there is a
fully completed solution
that hosts models but also
covers wide array of security,
prompt engineering, prompt caching.
There's a bunch of different solutions
that you can use on top
of Amazon Bedrock, okay.
So we are here to talk about
high regulated environments again
and we start talking about ISOs
and I said we are going
to return on this matter
further on the presentation.
So now it's the time.
When we are talking about
Amazon Bedrock compliance,
there is a bunch of different regulations
that we are already achievements.
So there is different ISOs as well.
We have SOC 1, 2, 3,
we are high PA eligible
and there is a different
for kinds of regulation
for different kinds of countries.
But there is one specific ISO
that I would like to highlight here.
So is the ISO 42001
and it is specific for
generative AI workloads.
And AWS with Amazon Bedrock
was the first provider
to get this iso.
So this is a real interesting thing
for when we are discussing this kind
of high grade environments and this ISO
is a really important
thing for the product,
for the Amazon Bedrock.
Here.
But the most common question
that I receive with my customers
and even around data and AI
concerns is about the data.
So I would like to highlight here is that
customer data is not used for AWS
to improve any foundation models.
And the customer data is not shared
between the other customers.
So your data is isolated
and AWS doesn't use this to retrain models
or to improve the Bedrock, okay?
So this is really important
when we are talking
about every environment
but for high regulated
environments as well.
Going forward,
so you can also choose which
model you would like to use.
So there's not a black box
where you have an end point
and then you send your
data and you don't, sorry,
and you don't know which
model you are using.
You choose the model that you wanna use.
You also put the correct permission
for your developers and builders
to use those models
inside of Amazon Bedrock
for your specific region.
So this is also important here, okay.
It's your choice which
model you're going to use,
which size of model you're going to use,
which region you're going to use it.
When you put your data in
a specific region on AWS,
your data remains in this specific region.
For some countries, like as Brazil,
this is really important.
We have some regulations around data,
data remains inside of Brazil.
The country of Brazil,
we cannot take this data
from the public sector of Brazil.
So this is important for our customers
and we'd like to highlight it here, right.
But you can do cross region
inferences if you want to.
So for example, you are using
Amazon Bedrock in Europe
and you you'd like to have
more latency for example
for your models, you can use
different regions for this,
but it is your choice which
region you're going to use.
So for example, if you are in Europe
and you are based on Europe AI Act,
you can use data inside all the Europe,
not only one country,
one specific country.
So you can create inference
profiles inside of Bedrock
with specific countries
that you can use it
and then make cross region
inference for your data
based on your regulations as well.
So this is your choice.
This isn't made by
default on Amazon Bedrock,
but you can use it to
improve the performance
but staying in your
regulated environment, right?
But let's talk about Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore, all right.
So over the last year
we've seen a AI evolves
from assistance to agents, right.
So now agents is the hype of the moment.
The main difference here is that
when we are talking about agents, agents,
we are talking about a solution
that works autonomously.
So it's not task defined.
He can work autonomously.
you can create your own agents using
open source solutions for example.
And I'm gonna let
Andries talk a little bit
how you can do this and what
is the have lift on top of it.
But AWS understood that this
is a need from our customers
and that's why we deliver
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore for the customer.
So if you guys doesn't know AgentCore yet,
you should take a look into it.
It's a real nice solution,
a real nice service.
We are probably gonna have a bunch
of new things in Re:invent
in the next month is a really new service.
But here, let's highlight some parts
of the Amazon Bedrock AgentCore that works
for high regulated environments
and that can help you
to stay within your regulations, okay.
So we have AgentCore runtime.
So you can run and host
your agent's purpose built.
It's serverless.
It's totally serverless, totally.
You don't need to deploy any
infrastructure inside of AWS
but each session of your agent.
So you defining some tasks for customers,
specific customers.
So for example, in financial
sector, you have a customer
that is running one solution
inside of the internet banking,
you can make each session
isolated from one to another.
This is really important
for regulated environments.
And Amazon AgentCore does this by default
when you are using AgentCore runtime.
So this is important,
one interesting solution on AgentCore
for high regulated environments.
The other one is AgentCore identity.
So it helps you to maintain,
secure your authorization,
authentication and
credentials for the customers.
So it's by the default you can put
the credentials for the customer
or in any kind of authentication
flow inside of AgentCore
and he will remains isolated
and can keeps this secure for you.
So it also helps when you are deploying,
developing your own agents on AWS.
Okay.
We also have sandbox environments
for code interpreter and browser tools.
You can also does this inside of AgentCore
without needing to developing anything
or deploying anything.
It's a solution, a service
that is inside of AgentCore
and you can just arrange which kind
of code interpreter you wanna use
or which kind of browser tool you wanna do
inside of the whole mechanism of Bedrock
with security, with
authentication inside of AWS.
So there's a bunch of other
solutions in AgentCore,
but I would like to highlight this three
because it's for the high
regulated environments,
Could be used for you guys
develop your agents on AWS, okay.
So going forward, when we
are talking about LLM models,
there's also a discussion
around which data was used
by this model to train.
How can I know if this
data has bias or not?
If it follows what I believe
it's correct for my company.
I would like to highlight here
the anthropic system cards.
So I dunno if you guys have heard of it.
You should read.
It's a really interesting
reading of 140 pages probably,
but you can read it.
It's really interesting and
explains how it was trained
and why is this trustworthy, okay.
So Anthropic is doing a real good job
inside of the transparency of
how they train their models
and which kind of data they are using.
We also have AWS
scorecards for Amazon Nova.
So you can see this on the
documentation of the Bedrock
and the Nova model
and there's also a bunch
of information over there
of how they were trained
and which kind of data they are using
and what AI responsible that
we were talking earlier.
That's also described for Amazon Nova
in this service cards, okay.
But even when we are talking
about all these different
perspectives of AI of regulated AI,
LLM models are a non-deterministic
technology, okay.
So you can also use guard
rails from Amazon Bedrock
to stay within what you believe
is the correct answer for
your end users, all right.
So don't believe that
the models will always
write the same thing.
He won't.
You should be able to prepare
to define your architecture
on top of this using solutions
such as guardrails should
stay within what is correct
for your end user when you are using
LLM solutions for end users.
This is really important, okay?
So you can also be aware of what the model
is going to respond and
also prepare for those
malicious user that we were
discussing with OWASP 10,
for example, the different
kind of users for Gen AI
for cyber attacks.
You can also use AWS guardrails
to help you with this
kind of issues, okay.
Sorry.
All right.
So now I will ask for
Andries to join me here.
He will explain how Holland Casino
is building their agents on AWS.
Andries please.
- Thank you, Amanda.
We are running about five minutes late
but I'll share very useful
tips at the end so please stay.
They are very important.
My name is Andries Krijtenburg
and I do indeed work for Holland Casino.
It might surprise you,
but Holland Casino was started
by the Dutch government about 50 years ago
with a clear mandate to offer
a safe environment for players.
Currently we run 13 casinos in Holland
and one online casino.
We operate under a very
strict gaming oversight
through the Dutch Gaming Authorities
that centers around player safety
and detection of fraud
and money laundering.
Now the stakes for us
are very high, right?
If you fail to meet these regulations,
casinos will close until
compliancy has been restored.
We will suffer reputational damage.
We have a very strong brand name
even by people that do not play.
Financial penalties,
they are seriously high.
It's more than a headache
and we face possible license suspension.
So apart from meeting these regulations,
we have other problems as well.
You see, regulations are subject
to political decision making,
changed frequent, sudden
and with fixed deadlines.
Sometimes we have three months,
a month even to change things.
Now the casino depends on
third party applications
for gaming concepts, gaming
machines, jackpot concepts,
casino management systems.
And the problem is that
these third parties
cannot move fast enough
as we like them to.
So we, Holland Casino,
need to have an environment
where we are in control and
have rapid response capabilities
and that's where we
ended up in Amazon Cloud.
In Amazon Cloud we build
our regulatory flows,
our regulatory reports and
the regulatory alerting.
And we do this since 2017.
And we do this with a very group
of very talented colleagues of mine from
not only technical people
like testers and developers,
but everybody like architects,
product owners, IT managers.
And we are assisted by
colleagues from Easytocloud.
Now over the years, as
a team, we really have
to come understand Amazon Cloud very well
to implement our regulatory use cases.
It's a growth period.
Now our success in internal believe in AWS
has seen us grown in Amazon
Cloud with more workloads.
So now we host our central
casino management system,
business intelligence, data
analysis using SageMaker
and even our legacy enterprise bus
we host in the cloud on EC2
because of its stability.
Now why am I telling you this?
You see, well our business culture
and maybe many of yours as well,
is to start small with an architecture,
gain confidence with it,
and then build the capacity to
execute regulatory use cases.
And this is exactly what we wanna do
with our AI architecture.
We wanna start small,
gain company-wide confidence
in the technology and then grow
and eventually have agents assist us
with regulatory use cases.
So briefly, our journey so far in Gen AI.
About a year ago we started
using code generation
with the Anthropic models in Bedrock.
Then we looked at Bedrock agents.
In Q2, Q3, we started
looking at Strands Agents
and those, we really liked
because they're really simple
and they show you laser on.
Then we started evaluating
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
to host these agents on.
I'll show you that as well.
AgentCore just came out of preview
and we are right now busy
putting them in production.
So we've been looking for a
small but important use case
and we found this in what we
call the management inside gap.
You see, management is always a need
for cost, security and
compliance oversight.
They will not log into the
Amazon console to get the data.
It is not the right tool for them, right?
So management, stakeholders,
especially the security
department came to us,
the internal team, my team,
to provide 'em with ad hoc reports.
And we created many Python
script to provide these reports
and this creates an unnecessary dependency
and it does not scale.
Now, the scripts that we write
for these ad hoc reports,
they come back later when we talk
briefly about Strands Agents.
So keep them in mind, all right?
So as a first use case,
we give management and stakeholder agents
that give them information they need
on a self-service basis.
And because we start off,
these are single agents
not yet busy with orchestration, yeah.
These agents centers around
costs, security and operations
and they can have a dialogue with them.
That is very important, right?
We use Strands Agents, why?
They're very simple and I'll
show you in the next slide.
They compact with tools
that you could use,
but it is very easy to
integrate your own tools
and your MCP servers.
It is Python based, we're a
Python shop, so it's easy for us
and it is open source so you
know exactly what is going on.
And this is a Strands Agent, yeah.
In the middle I declare my agent,
I give the model, in
this case a Bedrock model
and sonnet 4.5 and I
give it a system prompt.
Normally we craft a system
prompt. It's quite long.
We spend quite a lot of time
creating our system prompts.
But for space purposes,
I redacted it here.
And then they give it a tool,
in this case a billing tool.
Now remember, the scripts I
was talking about earlier on
these ad hoc scripts, it turns
out that this is fairly easy
to transform them into
tools for your agents.
So don't throw the scripts away, right?
Just make sure that you write
your system specification
or your tool specification really well.
That is really, really important.
Now I had an ad hoc report for billing
and I transformed it into IT
tool for my Strands Agents.
And once I've set it up,
I can invoke my agent.
I can say like,
well, what are my costs
so far this month, right?
And then it gives an answer.
And if you use sessions
IDs, you can delve into it,
you can have a dialogue.
You can ask like, well,
what were my costs?
What was it compared to last month?
Or I can delve into a service.
So you have a dialogue.
And this is what we want
to give our stakeholders.
Okay.
You got your Strands Agent,
it works on my machine
and I can guarantee you it works
on every one of yours machine.
It's easy.
However, we need to give it
to our stakeholders, right?
So we need to host it in Amazon Cloud.
We want it to scale,
we want it serverless,
we need to stream the responses,
and security is a non-negotiable.
So how do we do that?
So we take our agent,
we wrap it in fast API for streaming,
you package it in the Python project,
create your docker
files, your Lambda stack,
you build it for authentication
and authorization,
you make sure it versions very
well and then you deploy it.
And this will work. I've
done it, we've done it.
And if you wanna go this route,
you are fine.
However, if you say to me like,
Andries, that is a lot of boilerplate code
for a simple Strands Agent.
Is there another way?
Yes, there is, Bedrock AgentCore.
If you look at the right
hand side of the slide
in its simplest form, what you can do,
you can bring your agent
into the AgentCore run time
by wrapping it into an
Invoke Python method.
And your decorated method
with an app.entrypoint decorator.
You test locally as you normally would.
And some point you say,
AgentCore configure
on the command line.
And this builds all the boilerplate code
I just talked about in the previous slide.
Once you're happy with that,
you say AgentCore launch and
it launches it into production
into your Amazon environment.
So it's very easy for CICD integration,
even more brilliant for rapid prototyping.
If you go this route, you benefit
from all the other AgentCore
services that it offers
that Amanda spoke about earlier on.
So how does the architecture look like?
Simple.
We take the services as native
as possible, no magic sauce.
So in the middle here we
have our AgentCore agents.
They have access to
foundation models, guardrails,
memories, knowledge basis.
We use knowledge basis, RAGs as a service,
a better knowledge basis
to obtain our regulatory
information tools.
And then we've got two sets of apps
because in-house apps we develop ourselves
and third party apps.
The in-house apps we
host in Amplify Hosting
with Cognito User Pools,
federated to active directory,
Cognito Identity Pools.
We obtain temporary SDS access keys
and this gives you direct
access to the Amazon APIs.
In this case, InvokeAgent.
That is really powerful.
Third party applications that
do not have the capability
to access SDS tokens,
we just put an API gateway in between.
It's a bit more effort but
well worth the compromise.
If you look at the overall
picture on how we do this,
we basically has host our AI
architecture in two accounts
in pre-production and production.
Not different than any other application
we host in our environment.
And it is surrounded by what we normal,
in our normal multi account architecture
that takes care of security, compliance,
monitoring and networking.
Okay, my last slide and
hand back over to Amanda.
The lessons we learned in this path
of Gen AI in Holland Casino is that
AWS democratizes the use of Gen AI.
You do not have to study
four years at a university
in order to create well-crafted, stable
and scalable AI architectures.
So you can keep your DevOp methods,
you can keep on investing in
your current AWS knowledge,
especially Bedrock and Bedrock AgentCore.
Now this is important.
These are the tips I was speaking about.
That's why we place it
also in the box, right?
Expect non-deterministic
behavior of your agents
and mitigate the risks.
And here are some of our tips.
Fine tune your system
prompt of your agent.
Really important.
Give very clear instructions,
give the dos and the don'ts
and give a very clear output format.
That is really important.
You combine this with Bedrock guardrails.
Then agents must focus on one thing
and do this very well.
I had my first agent, I got very excited.
I uploaded all the tools that I had.
So one agent to rule them all.
The agent did not perform.
Why?
Because my tool specs
were not really specific
and the model struggled
to select the right correct tool, right?
So make sure that if you
need your lot of tools,
make sure that you're very
clear in tool specification.
Make sure you're very,
that the tool specification
don't overlap with each other
so that the model can
select the right tool.
If you set up knowledge basis,
what you must do is you must
invest in very realistic
evaluation jobs and you can
use Bedrock for that as well.
They give you very nice metrics.
Especially if your
knowledge base is in flux
when the data changes all the time
or where your agents start
using different models,
you need to rerun your evaluation jobs.
And the last one,
and that one is very
simple, but very important,
make sure that your end
users have a very easy way
of giving your feedback of
your agents in production.
Thank you. That's it for me.
I'll hand you back over to Amanda.
- Thank you, Andries.
Thank you Andries.
Thanks for sharing the Holland Casino.
So all right, guys.
Some final thoughts
and thank you guys for staying by the end.
It's a lot of content here.
In summary, we can use AI
to accelerate regulatory compliances.
Sicoob demonstrated how we can do this
on top of infrastructure using EKS
and Holland Casino with
Andries showed this,
how they develop this
using Strand Agents, okay.
So there is a bunch of
different paths to follow,
but you can achieve your regulatory needs
using generative AI on AWS, all right.
Where do I start? That depends.
That's the architecture
answer for all the questions.
You can start with a compliant foundation.
So you need to have a
standardized foundation
for run your workloads on AWS,
select your models as we discussed here.
Build your agents the way
that works better for you
and then deploy it in production in AWS
with your regulatory needs.
Okay.
Here's some resources.
So this is the first day of the event.
I hope you guys are enjoying the event.
There's some resources here
from the both perspective
that we discussed, both
with free infrastructures
and with Amazon Bedrock.
We are waiting for you
guys to take the photo.
Okay.
Some sessions to watch at re:Invent.
So saying again, this is
the first day of the event,
so we're gonna have a lot
of different contents here
with our colleagues from AWS.
You can take the pictures too. Okay.
Thank you all. Thank you for joining us.
Thank you for watching,
Staying by the end.
And I would like to also ask for you guys
to go into the app
and say if you like the
presentation or don't.
If you have any questions,
we'll be outside of this
stage from, I don't know,
maybe five or 10 minutes, okay.
Thank you, guys, and have a great event.
(audience applauding)